hey guys tim ferriss here before we jump
into this episode I'm gonna do something
I very rarely do and that is to make a
direct ask with hat in hand my brand new
book just came out today it is called
tribe of mentors subtitle short life
advice from the best in the world if you
like the podcast you will love this book
I reached out to 130 people who are the
best at what they do in sports investing
business acting directing you name it we
got it cryptocurrency done and it turned
out better than I ever could have
expected many of my friends think of all
my books it is the easiest to read the
easiest to use so check it out please
take a look I put out so much free
material the podcast is free the
700-plus blog posts are free every once
in a while I put out something like this
and it's not that expensive so please
take a look
tribe of mentors dot-com and it does
make a great holiday gift or gift for
others there's something for everybody
in here it is really a
choose-your-own-adventure guide a buffet
of options for improving your life both
in business and in the personal sphere
so take a look I appreciate you taking a
look tribe of mentors calm or anywhere
that books are sold at this altitude I
can once I have for a half-mile before
my hands start shaking your personal
question
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode's
brought to you by peloton and I'd heard
about peloton over and over again but I
ended up getting a peloton bike in the
whole system after I saw my buddy Kevin
Rose I've known him forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic I asked him as a dude
you look great what the hell have you
been up to because he's always doing a
weird diet or another but it only lasts
like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes in your schedule or
making it to a studio with some type of
commute etc new classes are added every
day and this includes options led by
elite New York City instructors in your
own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and design high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface two key
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's Oh n e PE l OT o n one peloton
calm and enter the code Tim all caps TI
m at checkout to receive $100 off
accessories with your peloton bike
purchase now you might say met
accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces no the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory category so this $100
off is a very legit hundred dollars off
so if you want to get in your workouts
if you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high-intensity
interval training or anything else or
you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone
check out peloton one pallet on.com and
enter the code to Tim again that's Ont
PE l o t-- o-- n dot-com and enter the
code Tim at checkout to receive $100 off
any accessories including the shoes that
you will want to get check it out one
peloton comm code Tim this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec founded by
the genius Finn's who lit the internet
on fire and you may have heard of their
mushroom coffee which features chaga and
lion's mane which has taken Silicon
Valley by storm I use it pretty much
every day either that or the chaga which
is decaf as a separate version and I use
both of these primarily for focus and
productivity they just get you going
light you up like a Christmas tree so
definitely check it out
people are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for the
right now this is the answer I try to
force this on all of my houseguests it
is a hell of a thing if I have employees
or people come over who aren't working
on projects with me I always
trying to feed it to them because I'm
going to get the limitless effect gets a
lot more out of them the first time I
mentioned this product and for sig Matic
on the podcast their products sold out
in less than a week so you may want to
check them out soon if you're listening
to this and the coffee tastes like
coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to 4 sig Matic calm forward
slash Tim that's for sig Matic fo you
are SI g ma TI c calm forward slash Tim
and use the code tim TI m to get 20% off
of your first order and they're not that
expensive anyway if you are in the
experimental mindset I do not think
you'll be disappointed to try my
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
you sexy little kittens this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or it is my job
to interview and deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types to
tease out the habits and routines
tactics thinking philosophies belief
structures that you can use and this
episode of kids if you're in the car
listening to this with your parents
earmuffs holy what a treat I am so
happy could not be happier with what you
were about to listen to and it's all
because of the guest and by way of
background when I was in Uzbekistan was
with Kevin Kelly and if you haven't
heard of Kevin Kelly you can check out
my interviews with him I have argued for
a very long time that Kevin may in fact
be the real world most interesting man
in the world but when I asked him we
were when we were in the back of a taxi
in Uzbekistan long story who I should
have on the podcast he gave me a very
very complete list but the first two
names were Tim O'Reilly and Stuart brand
and when I've asked Kevin who his
mentors are who he considers mentor as
the first name that he brings up is
Stuart brand so who is Stuart it's
Stuart is one of the sharpest most
badass guys you will ever meet and it's
kind of like Forrest Gump he shows up at
every possible historical moment you can
conceive of Stuart brand at Stuart brand
is the president of the long now
foundation established to creatively
foster long-term thinking and
responsibility in the framework of the
next 10,000 years
yes that's not a typo he leads a project
they're called revive and restore which
seeks to bring back extinct animal
species such as the passenger pigeon and
woolly mammoth Stuart is very well known
for founding editing and publishing the
Whole Earth Catalog which changed my
life when I was a little kid we talked
about it and it also received a National
Book Award for its 1972 issue and on top
of that and we delve into this Steve
Jobs talks about it in his most famous
commencement speech Stuart is the
co-founder of the well and global
business Network and the author of books
including polar discipline the clock of
the long now how buildings learn and the
Media Lab
he was trained in biology at Stanford
and served as an infantry officer in the
US Army Stewart can cover so many
different spheres of expertise and speak
intelligently on very very high concepts
ranging from evolution to the
nitty-gritty of designing say finite or
I should say rather infinite versus
finite games for different groups of
people it's just so much fun
to speak with Stewart and I've been
hoping to do this interview for a very
very very long time it came together and
maybe the caffeine level on my side was
right
I think Stewart's always on point but
I'm just thrilled with how it all turned
out so I will link to everything in the
show notes of course as usual that you
can find at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast and there will be a lot of links
but i really hope you enjoy this
conversation as much as i did so without
further ado please meet the one and only
an incredible Stewart Brant Stewart
welcome to the show howdy I have been
wanting to interview you for a very very
long time indeed and our mutual friend
Kevin Kelly who's I used to say was the
real-life most interesting man in the
world but I think you may actually give
him a run for the money and it's it's I
suppose appropriate that I'm recording
this from where I am on Long Island
where I grew up because at my parents
house which is is right next to me in
the shed I remember as a child going in
to find a single copy of the Whole Earth
Catalog and I would go to the whole
earth catalogue I'm exactly where it is
in the shed and I would sit down for
hours flipping around in this incredible
tome and I wanted to thank you for that
first and foremost because I had a real
formative impact on me in my childhood
years that's amazing I hear that a lot
I'm curious do you remember any of what
particularly got you
humming through the catalogue back then
yeah there were well there were a few
things and maybe you can create I've
actually never told anybody this so that
the first was I want to say that there
were geodesic domes or some sort of
graphic representations of geodesic
domes which at the time were just very
fascinating to me and I my my
grandfather was a classical sculpture on
one side and so is very interested in
shapes I wanted to be an illustrator and
a comic-book penciler for about 15 years
so anything that represented an unusual
what I felt was an unusual shape in the
physical world was very interesting to
me and then this could be a false memory
so please correct me if I'm wrong but as
a I don't know how all that was 9 or 10
year old maybe even younger
was there any not nudity necessarily but
were there any breasts of any type in
the whole earth catalogue because if so
that was probably also a big draw for me
yeah they were breasts that were
receiving a crotch I thank you the my
body myself which was this wonderful
book that came out on women's health by
women and it was just the facts man
graphic and and rich it was he because
of collective in Boston of women who put
it together and it was kind of a
revolution of users just taking hold of
medicine and revamping how it was
thought about and women were then and
probably now especially in need of
matter of facts and they were getting
from the male medical establishment so
the the answer I gave you I feel like
might be very trivial are there adduce
do you have any common answers that pop
up often when you ask people that
question about what stuck with them or
what really grabbed their attention
I suppose it probably depends on their
the age at which they came across it but
are there certain things that really
stick out oh well a common thing is wow
you did the whole earth catalogue it
really effect
in my life you know I still have the
original Whole Earth Catalog
and then I'll check and see if they mean
the very first one that came out in 1968
or only 2000 printed and know what they
mean is therefore first Whole Earth
Catalog which was probably the last old
Earth Catalog 1972 so-called and then
I'll ask them why do you still have it
and there's this wonderful silence and
I've never gotten a good answer I think
it has something to do with a sense of a
certain era or a certain period in the
life of that person kind of coming of
age and coming into who they were and
who they wanted to be and the catalog I
guess they felt was some kind of enabler
or a tipping point from one way of
thinking about what they could do to
another way of thinking about it so
anyway a lot of people who kept them
there's no end of basements and attics
that have holders no.11 one fan who
comes to mind and I'm sure there are
many who have name recognition but is
Steve Jobs so he I mean he referred to
you in his Stanford commencement speech
which of course has become very very
popular and he refers to the amazing
publication called the Whole Earth
Catalog one of the Bible's of my
generation have you spent any time did
you spend any time with Steve and get an
idea of why why it had such an impact on
him I did spend time with Steve a few
times and we did in fact you can find on
youtubes and videos we did together for
the Library of Congress
we're both Library of Congress asked
both of us to help promote a new program
they were doing we're both glad to do it
and so we sat down together and did some
fun stuff that was also when Steve put
out his personal computers or bicycle of
the mind that vastly enable and
everything
I never got to ask Steve was at the end
of that commencement speech what he put
out to the Stanford students was what
had been on the back cover of the whole
earth epilogue which came out in 73 74
and it said stay hungry stay foolish and
for some reason that really got Steve
and his commencement talk was wonderful
because it was basically about only give
us three stories but the main story is
that he's been scared to death by his
pancreatic cancer diagnosis and lived at
least for a good and important while and
so from that perspective he was kind of
giving the students a little bit of a
signal from the other side of a
temporary grave and that it's part of
what made it such an amazing talk and
it's one line basically the students
would stay hungry stay foolish and the
question I never had a chance to ask
Steve even though I did see him for
lunch after that talk was what got him
about that and various people including
me have tried to interpret why he in
particular was moved by stay hungry stay
foolish but I think he was putting in
our own position of at that point a
whole hell of a lot of power and by then
also wealth and he was into issues like
the innovators dilemma of how do you
keep her business from clinging to its
past so much that becomes part of the
past and how do you keep revolutionizing
your own process your own thinking your
own business your own whatever and I
think he was using I'm surmising maybe
he was using stay hungry stay foolish
as a sort of a refreshment exercise what
was intended by stay foolish stay hungry
I feel like I can interpret in a number
of ways that I would probably have some
consensus
on with other people what what about the
stay foolish what was intended by that
elaborate the back cover of the holy
sepulcher photograph I commissioned that
was meant to look like sunrise of that a
hitchhiker might see on some roadside
and it was in relation to a photograph
of the earth at the moment of the Sun
just coming around just making a
crescent of so the the limb of the earth
basically is just a crescent of light
the Sun so you know that sunrise
happening somewhere on earth and so I
wanted to get that from the surface but
the dawn someone's eyes must meet the
dawn the dawn hitchhiker is handed
wherever the next drivers headed in a
way and that's a way to get through life
but it's also a randomizing way to get
to wherever you're going I think I was
promoting the idea of occasionally you
staying random Niki case just recently
gave one of our long now talks where he
points out that chaos is an important
part of keeping creativity and evolution
everything else going the story and
evolution is what the goal Fitness
landscapes in the biologist from 50s I'm
really won over by them the idea of a
fitness landscape is it's a series of
hills and mountains and typically when
the species is evolving it'll evolve to
a local optimum the local optimum might
be just the hill and have to be near
bike it's better and better and better
going up that hill and gets to the peak
and then it stays there but all around
it may well be much higher peaks of much
greater opportunity much greater fitness
whatever it may be but slogs is focusing
on being really really good and being on
top of the hill it's on it will never
get to those mountains the only way
we'll get to those mountains is by being
foolish by trying weird
by being random by recombination or
mutating sort of down off the hill a
little bit maybe even down into the
nearby valley which looks horrible and
then trying new things that improve on
the new slope around which could well be
a higher mountain so it gets you off the
low hill fitness to potentially a high
mountain of fitness is randomness of
that stay polish has that been a
conscious decision on your part
throughout your life to insert
randomizing function or is it really
just been serendipity no I'm just
worried you've lived so many lives
intimidated by the interviews I'm like
how the hell I haven't where'd where's
where should I start where's the
beginning where is the end it's very
challenging so I'm just curious how you
thats something you've thought about as
you've made decisions in your own life
yes I can tell him the my version of
randomness is pretty low threshold of
boredom okay Gil I brought because you
know the way that works is you know like
with the various sports and they came
all the skydiving came alone now that
doesn't count because I stopped doing
that because I had a parachute not open
but hang gliding came along and or
snowboarding those were two sports today
as soon as they showed up I I got into
it and pretty quickly I just ran out of
a excitement up the hill down the hill
up the hill down the hill in both cases
and I bailed I bailed out of a lot of
interesting things it is a not good
career advice in terms of scoring big
because his Brian Eno has pointed out to
me and to others the way to make a lot
of money is to have a very good idea and
then be extremely careful never to have
another I haven't heard that before oh
yeah that's true for artists history and
business is true and all sorts of things
that you know you sort of develop an
expertise you get rewarded for it and if
it really looks like it is one of those
mount opportunities temptation is just
keep storming up the mountain
what could after after a while you can
sort of see what the limits are or you
find yourself doing the same mental and
physical things day after day after day
after day and meanwhile other stuff is
kind of tempting or they just show up a
lot of my stuff and just showed up I'm
dealing with a biographer now and he's
raising some of these same questions and
when I thought about doing a memoir I
thought about using a title from our
Kesler about astronomy is called The
sleepwalkers and those things that I
progressed from one to another they were
not part of any arc of ambition or even
narrative arc they were just sort of
what seemed like a good idea at the time
based on what was around me so I think
biographies including mine consists
mostly of circumstance and sequence and
then you map onto that character and any
stories or something you tell backwards
alright so I want to dissect the the
stories or things that you tell
backwards in a second but first there's
something you mentioned in passing that
I feel like I have to address as it's
sort of a pink elephant in the room that
my listeners are going to ask me about
if I don't ask you which is you
mentioned I did skydiving for a while
but then I had a parachute not open I
took care born training when I was an
army officer and when I was stationed at
Fort Dix skydiving was just starting to
come along as the thing that you could
do the US Army at a skydiving team
and things like that and so this is in
61 62
we were New Jersey and just a couple of
the local guys got together and we
started we would take military shoots in
and cut Gore's in the side and then a
section out of the back and then put
sort of peg strings up to where the
Gore's were and by pulling on the string
she could sort of steer and it would
sort of go forward and then we'd write a
plane and jump out and do I don't know
first jump and pull and then five second
delays and so on and it was great fun
and by then teaching basic training at
Fort Dix was boring for for all of us
officers had been in for a year and a
half at that point so then when I got
out of the Army in the 62 um there was a
by then a pretty good temperature
skydiving scene going on in Northern
California so I joined that and was
jumping on the weekend this up near
Calistoga northern napa valley and it
was young in dangerous sport at that
time was still a parachute army
parachutes and I'd taken from the Army
and I had adapted or I guess I'd had
guys who are doing adaptations do it and
one of the times I jumped out and I
think I was doing a 10 second delay and
you're sort of counting 1,000 2,000
3,000 4,000 and I got to my count and
pull the parachute you reach across
yourself and pull the ripcord and then
the parachute comes out and there's kind
of sudden stop and then you just really
Pleasant long integer so glide down to
where you're gonna try to land on the
target and this Idol was interrupted by
the fact that the parachute was not
opening and there was I could said there
was crap going on behind me and the
great thing about parachute training in
the Army is that you go through a lot of
stuff before you
the parachute doesn't open there's a
reserve chute little stuff together
laundry thing on the front of your
remains shoots on the back and there's
this little chute front and one of the
things you're told is if you have to
open the reserve you know go for it and
then turn sideways in the air because if
you're facing tree down in the standard
position your skydive in the chute will
open around you and besides being dead
on arrival you'll already be in her
shroud so uh I had this wonderful moment
of Oh
suddenly the spotlight is on me I could
see San Francisco in the distance I'm
facing that direction and sort of had
those cosmic thoughts and I also had at
that point eight seconds to live so
before I would be a greasy spot and what
I found myself doing was where I was
trained to do and this is one of the
things that persuaded me to training
it's better than almost any other form
of instruction which is a rotated 90
degrees in the air reach for the reserve
chute pulled it it popped out with a
terrible jerk and then I had the
somewhat faster crews down to the ground
without any ability to control it which
was alarming because the wind was taking
me towards some power lines
anyway I landed and that was that and
there was late in the day so I didn't go
back up maybe I was afraid to go back up
but I did go back up the following
weekend I did a very dangerous job I
almost hit my head on the step leaving
the small playing I never really
stabilized and freefall and basically it
was a screwed-up jump and that persuaded
me that my body was not happy doing
parachuting anymore so I stopped okay I
think that's a very reasonable
conclusion by the way what caused the
malfunction was um the pilot tooth that
jumps out of your backpack first and
then pulls out the sleeve which then
reveals the parachute
so it opens a less than totally sudden
way that pilots who jumped out and the
tether that it was on managed to tie an
overhand knot in the bottom thusly
so even if I'd spent my eight seconds
trying to undo the tangle whatever still
been tugging at the knot when I hit the
ground was there was there any other
training or principles that you took
from the middle of your military
experience that ended up being helpful
later well there's a lot of instruction
I was taking I was lucky I took her ROTC
at Stanford and then did two years
active duties and as I graduated and
then often went to Fort Benning two
officers basic training course and there
I got all most of the basics of small
unit management and leadership that ie
generation of liberal types mostly did
not get so you know me and John Kerry
and a few others uh and it was you know
just simple things like okay you're
responsible for the people in your
command you're going to critique them to
get them doing ever better especially
the sergeants the work for you and the
way you begin at ich is by telling the
sergeant what here now she has been
doing very well and thank you for that
and it's got to be close and it's got to
be accurate and well observed and then
you say but on the other hand there's I
think one thing you could be working on
and probably not more than one thing are
you overwhelmed and you've given
something to work on for improvement and
let them know you're going to be
watching this he science of that
improvement which he will you know
congratulate them for when it shows up
and then come up with some other item of
potential improvement just that sequence
of telling what they're doing right
before telling them what they're doing
wrong that's the kind of thing that you
know good management instruction does
and you know there's none at taxpayer
expense thank you very much I want to
talk about the haulers catalog a little
bit more and and I know that you've
probably told many stories about the
Whole Earth Catalog
but for those people who are listening
who don't have context I want to read
just a short quote which is from a piece
from The Guardian so they have a little
bit of context and I'm gonna borrow from
a couple of different pieces but the
Whole Earth Catalog has been called the
Internet before the internet and then
quoting from this piece
it wasn't exactly a book it was a how-to
manual a compendium and encyclopedia
literary review and opinionated life
guide and a collection of readers
recommendations and reviews of
everything from computational physics to
go to husbandry and it seemed even as a
kid reading this book that it was the
type of project that would take a lot
out of a person
so rather than come then go into the
creation of it necessarily although we
could I we could certainly get into it I
had not been a not been aware that at
least based on some of the reading I did
when you shut down the whole earth
catalogue what followed was a pretty
severe depression and you and I saw each
other not too long ago at Ted where I
spoke for the first time on the main
stage and decided two weeks beforehand
that I would completely redo my
presentation and talk about severe
depression and how close I came to
suicide at one point in college would
you mind sharing with people a little
bit of that period in your life and what
you found helpful to regain your footing
well I saw that TED talk to him what I
liked about it especially and a lot of
people like it's doing very well online
I was the fear gaming aspect of that
these sort of catalogue the things
you're actually worried about and then
work through on each one uh you know
what happens if it actually happens what
do you deal with that how can you hit it
off and enter to take it apart in detail
rather than just go along with this sort
of blank I'm too afraid to make this
move approach the things I really like
that is something I think we're gonna
find a way to use for some of the people
who get worried about the use of
genetics and conservation which is what
I do much um fantastic but um back then
I think I stopped the catalog partly
because I thought it was a good idea to
stop something and it's sort of peak of
success I'll just see what would happen
I was kind of you know feline curiosity
but it wasn't that then I became
depressed I also was eager to shut it
down by 1971 because I was stressed and
it was combination of marriage probably
that was going sour great is it had been
for a few years and various things they
often go on with first-time success I
didn't know how to has yet to modulate
my work and schedule and so I was living
at the office most at that time oh how
old were you at the time just to place
us um so basically 30 31 32 right in
there I've got it and by now people who
at that age have been through three or
four failures and successes and whatnot
those days it was still my first and I
was considered young at the time to be
having a national scale publication of
great interest to a lot of people um
there was not money issues it was a
non-profit so I
just getting a non-profit salary of
10,000 a year or something like that
the fame part I think was not
particularly problematic I mean as you
know any kind of fame can lead you into
a kind of a self caricature sequence
where he you wind up being driven around
by your image rather than vice versa but
that was not really an issue either I
think is vacation lists overworked and
tough marriage and couple years to get
out of it and do of course it did
here's later I had another one they come
they go I am now a great fan of drugs
like Zoloft that can take my case
depression had occasional panic type
attack and sell-off is fabulous against
panic attacks so you found that the
panic preceded the depression it was
sort of a triggering event or a
triggering that I would say it was a I
think one of the elements and you know
who knows what triggers would true
actually there was a recent trigger in
the sense that um I had a vertigo
experience in the middle of the night
when I just turned over to the right and
suddenly the bedroom is spinning and my
wife Ryan is trying to settle me down
and we go off to the emergency room and
the guy Barris is oh yeah it's rare to
go pretty common but and you know
there's a maneuver that you can turn
your head in certain way and then you
get the thing that's causing the
vertical vertigo that's in your middle
ear to go to the right place so it
doesn't do that anymore it's fabulous
correction but at a particular time is
first time my brain or my brain body had
sort of frightened me like that and so I
was fearful for a year or two after that
and part of that would be kind of
panicking at the kind of
people panic at uh standing around for a
long time in public or driving on a
bridge things like that and so loft is
great it just cuts the peak right off of
any kind of panic and then you realize
it's you're not you know gets scared
about panicking right you don't start
panicking about the panic you've got it
and and then just by taking the peak of
fearfulness ways and the whole thing
gets under control so now that we're on
the subject of broadly speaking
pharmacology I had read that well I'd
heard someone referred to you actually
was overhearing not reading referred to
you as a pioneer early pioneer in
psychedelics but that you had stopped
but that you had stopped and I'm curious
to know why that why that is and if you
could give us any any backstory on that
well I have to be in the Bay Area when
LSD was first being researched by then
at that point still legally as a sort of
a psychological fitness um a way to do
psychotherapy to do severely enhanced
psychotherapy which by the way has come
round again now it's kind of fun to see
and I think a lot of it applied so you
know using MDMA on post-traumatic stress
syndrome and things like that which are
a friend Rochard felt weird Richard
Rockefeller was pushing strongly until
just before he died that's good stuff
but so then these drugs were around um a
lot I never actually bought a
psychedelic drug people would there's so
much of it in the 60s at this point that
just the marijuana and hashish at people
gave me LSD that people gave me the mask
of money people gave me um other
sessions going on that I would join in
and then I joined the Native American
church formally and was I went to for a
number of peyote meetings and then round
wound up leading one or two
was a road man and it sounds like I was
doing all the drugs in the world but
compared to my contemporaries
it was pretty modest and I did see a few
people who thought that the problem that
might be caused by bad trips from LSD
was to do more LSD and I was pretty sure
that that was not the direction of look
for a solution um so one I had some bad
trips and some good trips and wound up
the last one was in 1969 the occasion of
Ken Kesey and the Merry Pranksters and
they were bus in New Mexico having a
race with a hog farm bus and the great
bus race I go step on a certain amount
of LSD and that was a fun and amazing
experience and also the last time I did
LSD after that I continued to do nitrous
oxide for a while nitrous having the
advantage of being completely legal at
and I can eat ank delivered weekly at my
office and and nitrous you do a flash
and if you like the flash you can do
another if you don't like the flash new
stop so it's a little more
self-correcting in that respect but one
day I just kept flashing I think I was
listening to the Beatles probably
Sergeant Pepper and and the world went
away and then I was a whole other side
of a large room and my wife is shaking
me saying you're laughing hysterically
this laughing gasps after all but
clearly I had gone over some of the edge
with nitrous oxide so I stopped doing
that why did you stop doing it was the
LSD than a matter of the cessation a
matter of legality at that point oh god
no oh well I could be but you know
everything was illegal so
I I you know Ken Kesey did this event we
he called the acid test graduation and
partly it was finessing his legal
problems but it also was an
acknowledgment that you go through the
doors of perception that all this Huxley
talks about and you're in this cosmic
place and then the trip is over in your
back and you go back through there's the
cosmic place and you go back to the
ankle-biters the cosmic place and
there's terrifying versions and exalted
versions but in a sense it's the same
cosmic place as so two things happen one
I got sort of recognized that there
wasn't a lot of news anymore and a sort
of side effect was I became much more
suspicious about mysticism in general
which I studied in college both
Christian mysticism and everybody else's
mysticism and they had a feeling like
I'd taken the shortcut into that world
and there wasn't as much there as I had
thought and hoped same way I might come
back to that for people who don't know
the name Ken Kesey he's the author of
other things One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest and then the he the pranksters in
the rip-roaring ride that you mentioned
also led you to appear just as a point
of trivia please correct me if I'm wrong
in Tom Wolf's the electric kool-aid acid
test so just as a side note because you
you make these appearances in so many
defining cultural works or moments it's
almost like watching Forrest Gump but
with someone who's not for us government
it's really astonishing well I'm on the
box of chocolates you know you really do
not know what you're gonna get approach
to things but yeah I got lucky but
partly by choice I'm in a
very over you know specializes in doing
weird stuff in the San Francisco Bay
Area and you run into a lot and wind up
connecting with a lot that turns out to
be important just by sort of strolling
around can you tell us about the about
Blue Marble so the can you tell us about
the buttons that you distributed or I
guess you were selling them way back in
the day and give us a little bit of
context
okay the Blue Marble you're referring to
is the look at the Earth from space yeah
and we're still talking about drugs
because I was bored in the spring of
1966 and on my rooftop in North Beach
San Francisco I took sort of a half a
dose maybe a hundred hundred 50
micrograms my curl whatever's microphone
yeah of LSD and uh just had a nice long
thoughtful afternoon that was colored by
having listening to a fair amount of
buckminster for lectures and read his
books over the previous months where he
had said that um people assume that the
resources of the earth are infinite and
in their mind the earth is flat and if
they would just understand that the
earth is really a sphere with a limited
amount of surface and resources
everything else then they would behave
better and then they're stoned looking
out of the San Francisco skyline
and um imagine to myself that I can see
that the buildings are all vertical but
they're not exactly parallel they
diverge slightly because of the
curvature of the earth and sort of the
fisheye thing happening in my mind and
then I imagine well if I went up a
little ways I would see that even more
strongly what up further still in
altitude I would have the horizon to
close on itself
obvious circle and then I guess I took
my mind further out this kind of a star
maker story almost able to this story
begins this way and then in my mind I
saw the earth not only as a circle but
as a sphere rotating against a star
field I thought now that's that is
really the way to see the earth but it's
weird that we haven't seen that because
this is 1966 Sputnik went up in 1956 so
the Soviet Union and America had been in
space for at that point ten years and
there were no end of photographs of the
moon and the beginnings of satellite
photography of parts of the Earth's
surface but nobody had ever turned the
camera back on the earth from one of
these remote probes to see what the
earth looked like from a distance and so
the kind of LSD concentration which is
and we called it a psychedelic meaning
might expanding but I think it's
actually a mind contracting drug where
you're really focus on your hand or the
song that's playing or whatever it is
the fire I was really focused on gee
what do I do to make people aware of the
importance of the image of the Earth
from space and when I came up with this
concept of a button that you mentioned
that would say oh why don't we see a
photograph of the hole yeah I was sort
of putting the paranoid terms so that
and it's a question that people would
you know raised the question I had how
come we've been in space for ten years
and this photograph hadn't been made the
implication was that had been made they
were hiding it from us and then I
printed those buttons up in the next
week and made some kind of posters and I
went and started selling those buttons
for 25 cents apiece from a sandwich
board at saving gate at UC Berkeley and
Stanford an IT and Harvard Square
in Columbia University and gotten in the
newspapers The Village Voice and I sent
buttons to various people including
Buckminster Fuller and Marshall McLuhan
and I sent him two senators and
congressmen and to their secretaries I
sent him to people at NASA I sent him to
people in the Politburo in Moscow and
anyway it was just a campaign so that
when the photographs from Apollo started
to come in good color photographs the
Earth from the moon missions I was sort
of proven right that would make a
difference in indeed it reframed
everything I think up till then in my
lifetime the sort of way you thought
about the planet planets fate was in
terms of the mushroom cloud of atomic
bombs and from 1969 1970 on the image
now that we think about the Earth's fate
with is no longer mushroom clouds it's
the photographs of the Earth from
outside you mentioned Buckminster Fuller
and he seems to have been very
influential in or had an influence
certainly on you in some way what was
most striking about him or what did you
take what have you taken from
Buckminster Fuller you know there's a
wonderful chapter in Peter Drucker's
early memoir but you call it something
like observations of a bystander and in
it he has a chapter about hippie
jerry-san about two of his friends which
was Marshall McLuhan and Buckminster
Fuller and he said McLuhan and four were
these two voices in the wilderness
shouting away with nobody listening and
he said both of them would turn up at
his door and come in and sort of you
know grant their various rants at him
and he would patiently listen to them
and encourage them in the jaw of the
door and what happened in the sixties is
artists that I was hanging out with a
new you
a group called osco were paying close
attention to both Marshall McLuhan at
Buckminster Fuller and they were
regarding how we thought about being
artists Peter Drucker's perspective was
that this was the first generation to
take sort of technology and engineering
seriously um as a guide to important
helpful intellectual endeavor that up
till then intellectuals had sort of
looked down from a great height on
scientists looked down on engineers and
technology was seen as you know
something that one kind of a suffered
rather than grabbed and ran with and he
felt that the 60s generation reversed
that that we started grab pieces of
technology and run to our own horizons
with them and we're ready to listen to
profits of that such as Marshall McLuhan
saying that the medium is the message in
Buckminster Fuller saying that if all
the politicians in the world died next
week the world would barely notice but
of all the scientists and engineers in
the world died next week the world would
cease to function that was a big part of
you know what the Whole Earth Catalog
took on much more from Florida and from
fluid in that sense though I later got
to know both of them especially Bucky
there's there's a quote then I found
that may or may not be relevant but I'd
love to explore it a little bit and that
is I believe attributed to you you you
can't change human nature but you can
change tools you can change techniques
and then by so doing you can change
civilization is that something you could
expand on and related to that is do you
think of thinking as one such tool that
you could change instead of
human nature I just love to know where
that came from or how it applies in your
own mind um that definitely comes
directly from fuller fuller is a lot
basically yeah that the changing human
nature's is hard and when you try you
mostly fail and it's discouraging and
changing tools and technology is
relatively easy and you can enable
things and so we saw that played out in
the 70s when the new left was still in
vogue and seemingly powerful and
personal computers were coming on and so
here in the Bay Area you had people in
Berkeley demonstrating and saying power
to the people
and you had Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak
basically saying power to people it's
provides the tools and the rest will
come that's been a pretty reliable
framing a later version of that that I
came up with is a sort of proclamation
this science is the only news all the
other stuff of politics goes in cycles
the fashion goes in very very tight
little cycles and even the technology is
pretty predictable if you if you've got
a good eye what the science is up to so
the that's in a sense moving almost from
a grab tools and run with them to tools
are arriving all the time just pay
attention and that's I think where most
of what we consider progress comes from
now does that apply to thinking and I
ask because of the seminars about
long-term thinking yeah well that's
curved busted okay I was about to say no
clearly I can't
I got to hang out with people in the Bay
Area at SR I and the late 60s who are
doing a thing called Augmented human
intellect this was Doug Engelbart and
his merry band at Stanford Research
Institute and and now that that is then
played out and so John Markoff came out
with this good book year or two ago
called the machines of love and grace
which basically spelling out the the
ongoing debate between artificial
intelligence and basically intelligence
augmentation I am AI intelligence so
augmented intelligence I think has been
going on ever since humans got around to
developing language and that then
becomes individual intelligence becomes
much more social intelligence I think
almost all intelligence is social
intelligence anyway
and their personal computers came along
they were mainly a communication device
they did some calculations on modeling
and games and whatnot but mainly how the
goddess was you know email and then web
and and on and on social intelligence is
really easily augmented with tools now
what do you do with social intelligence
can you change that that's something
you're in the business of and I suppose
I'm in the business of to a lesser
degree the idea of the long now
foundation is to kind of give
encouragement and permission to a
society that is rewarded thinking very
very rapidly business terms in
in scientific terms too rapid turnaround
get inside the adversaries loop and fast
and break things and the long-term
thinking might be proposing uh some
things you probably don't want to break
[Laughter]
they might involve moving slow steadily
the climate changes the one that our
century our generation has been handed
is a thing to which there is no quick
fix whatsoever it's a big slow problem
caused by absolutely everybody and any
solution is going to have to be big and
slow and caused by approximately
everybody so that is that's not tool
that's that's a circumstance that
situational but I think what we're
proposing is that there are a lot of
problems a lot of issues or a lot of
quite wonderful things in that category
of being big and slow-moving and so I
want to with Brian Eno developing a pace
layer diagram of civilization where
there's the fast moving person like
fashion and commerce and then it goes
kind of slower when you get to
infrastructure and then things from
we're really slow and how Governor Nance
changes and then you go down to culture
language and religion we were really
really slowly in the nature tectonic
forces and climate changes Congress
really big and slow and what's
interesting about that is is that the
fast parts get all the attention but the
slow parts have all the power
and if you really want to really deal
with the powerful forces in the world in
barrel a Shinto seeing what can be done
with appreciating and maybe helping
adjust the big slow things so when you
look for instance if somebody wanted to
start exploring some of the slower
moving lay
in topics you've been curating salts
which I referred to earlier the seminar
is about long-term thinking and you've
released a very affordable book it's
basically a a collection of summaries
think it's $2.99 of many of the talks at
this point which include I mean you name
it Michael Pollan Matt Ridley it's a
very very long list on there Paris
Tim Ferriss and there you have about on
meta-learning which was a lot of fun and
it's a great honor are there any
particular if for people who wanted to
perhaps take a break from the perishable
goods of so-called news non-scientific
news and fashion and all of that noise
to think about the slower moving
extremely powerful layers are there any
talks that you might suggest they they
start with or any summaries well I'm
going to have to scroll through them but
one that comes to mind is Matt Ridley
talking about rational optimism there's
a good one by Ian Morris on basically
the West sort of one the world for now
it's a sort of Jared Diamond level of
understanding of how civilization is is
moved in relation really to the makeup
of the planet you're a diamond is so
neat Jared gave one of the talks on and
the main one I think is Guns Germs and
Steel book though his collapse book also
has some interesting stuff to propose
I'd have to go down the list you have
some of that you particularly like oh
well I mean I'm looking for a shopping
list basically because I've I think in
the last few months become particularly
sensitive to the fact that I've been
pulled out by the Riptide of
[Music]
noise I think and I'm so I'm actually
looking for homework list from you more
than anything else well I'm looking at
the seminars homepage and at the long
now foundation and we've done I guess
120 hundred and 30 of these talks now
and they're about as long as this
broadcast they're 90 minutes in the
sense so it's long form it's like
long-form TED Talks they're illustrators
so there's really good edited videos of
them but a lot of people use the iPod
I'm sure they do with your stuff you
know when they're writing to work or
something like that but just some of the
recent ones Jim Glick in a version of
his book time travel is some of the most
cogent thinking about time that I think
we've seen in a long time
uh-uh Kevin Kelley is done two or three
now Jesse AuSable did one on how nature
is rebounding there's it's not widely
known that we're pretty much at peak
farmland
now and that's fantastic
more and more of these bat grown or
lab-grown
synthetic meats come along I think will
will start to be have fewer of the
Laskey being given over to grazing which
will then free up a lot of nature which
is where I like to see things happening
Geoffrey West his book scale I did a
talk version of that which is tastic
particularly he focused on cities and
how cities are quite different from
businesses in the sense that as they get
bigger they become even more innovative
whereas when companies get bigger they
become less innovative and he is a
theoretical physicist who has developed
a scale a logarithmic scale model of
understanding of how that happens and
why that is the case it's not like that
so these are I need to immediately after
we're done talking jump back
again because I've been feeling a deep
hunger for revisiting and while visiting
for the first time a lot of these you
mentioned table I because you're tired
of the daily melodrama in the White
House or what
I'm tired of daily melodrama period I
think that whether it's self
manufactured emergencies or anxiety or
shiny objects that are distractions
I've actually and I don't want to take
us to off the rails but I mean I've been
I hesitate to use the word mysticism you
mentioned that after having some of
these psychedelic experiences you felt
like you'd peek behind the curtain in a
sense and that some of the maybe appeal
or draw of mysticism was decreased I've
I've had the opposite experience and
have been increasingly drawn to reading
about definitions of reality and looking
at perception and the doors of
perception and and really trying to pull
back from I was just chatting with Tim
O'Reilly about this actually but the if
we were to look at say reality and then
one abstraction of that being our
personal experience as perceived through
the senses and then language and
additional abstraction on top of that
I've been trying to return to I hate to
use this term but I'm not coming up with
anything better on the spot source or
the lete layer of least abstraction to
start to study that to the extent
possible because I think it informs
everything else that's upstream so
there's probably a book or two is
speaking to you at this point what's
what are they huh well I will tell you
that I've been reading so there are
there are books that are speaking to
this but they might not be what people
would expect they're not they're
actually not nonfiction I think I've
tried to look in nonfiction for answers
but there is a very kinesthetic feeling
of greater truth which will make certain
rationalist out there just drop their
jaws open but I've spent my whole life
operating out of my prefrontal cortex
and using spreadsheets and pro and con
lists and so on and I think that for a
long time I viewed my emotions or
intuition or feelings as a liability and
distraction and nothing else and I've
come to believe otherwise so I'm I've
actually spent a lot of time reading
certain poetry which is very much not
anything who grew up with me would
associate with me but also reading the
autobiographical fiction that questions
the nature of perception for instance
Milan Kundera's the book of laughter and
forgetting is I think just a tremendous
tremendous work that it uses hilarity
and absurdity to teach a lot so the
that's one that comes to mind because I
literally just finished it yesterday and
it's sitting on my table but what what
what books are you drawn to right now
well come to that I want to say a little
more about what you're talking about
staying comfort in in the larger frame
the longer frame and apparently there's
some research done this a few years back
Danny Hillis is referred to I have never
seen the actual research but um when
people are doing something they care
about for a long-term institution they
care about might be a church might be a
branch military therein might be the US
government might be a species that are
dedicated to they take comfort in
engaging the time frame of that
institution or thing and I think one of
the comforts may be when you're dealing
with the institution that's lived longer
than any human or a natural system
there's obviously been longer
than humans themselves have been around
and you extend your mind back through
the narrative the sequence of events the
story of that thing and then you extend
it forward any extended forward you go
by a thing which might otherwise obsess
you which is your own personal death and
denial of death is a big event and
things that sort of finesse death
without denying it by taking on the life
of something that lives longer than you
do um people get this from their
children and grandchildren obviously um
that's why the loss of a child is harder
on a parent than any other thing I think
but this is a place that people like to
abide from time to time and it's it also
feels like the opposite of the daily
melodrama uh which has its own
attractions God knows and you know it's
just part of balance I think is having
this other frame of reference and some
get it from religions and get it from
the pasta and meditation and some get it
from cleaving to a a long term thing of
species or an institution um I think
that's one of the reasons that the long
now foundation which is a you know kind
of a strange thing that would be
successful is it that it's what I was
doing is saying long-term thinking is
probably good let's build a ten thousand
year o'clock and see if that helps uh
and surprising number of people say oh
good idea and then a lot of engage in
some fashion either by listening to
these talks or becoming members or
eventually when the clock is finished in
a few years going and hanging out with a
clock in my case and trying to bring
back woolly mammoths and that's going to
take a couple of centuries oh so I'll
just get out start
that one on 78 that's comforting there's
so many different directions we could go
with this I want I know know I know I
can see them branching out in your mind
I know the dendrite two possibilities
are branching out and I think I think
I'm gonna go much like the parachute not
opening I feel like for the people
listening I have to address the wooly
mammoth
yeah so that so thank you for that easy
option and I I shouldn't assume but I
will if is this related to revive and
restore yeah reviving restores
organization that my wife Ryan Phelan
runs that we've been working on for for
almost five years now
to basically bring genetic technology to
wildlife conservation and the general
term for what we do and and the
sub-discipline is opening up in
conservation biology is called genetic
rescue and mainly are focusing on other
work or genetic workarounds for
inbreeding depression in small
populations that one would like to have
come back to be large populations maybe
this is a small group of California
condors left in captive breeding and
then you want to get them back out to
the wild which has now happened and the
genetic monitoring of that helps with
the breeding program for example head
off diseases to maybe dial down a severe
severely destructive invasive rodents on
Ocean islands for example things like
they can do it genetics that case maybe
were chain drive which is a very
aggressive form of genetic intervention
um and then the extreme case is because
we now have recoverable DNA from animals
that have gone extinct well there was
just a hundred years ago like the
passenger pigeon or several thousand
years ago like the woolly mammoths and
if there are close relatives to those
extinct animals that are
still living they have working genomes
in the case of the woolly mammoth it's
Asian elephants um then you can
contemplate or in our case working with
George Church at Harvard begin to apply
the taking of the most mammoth II of the
mammoth genes identifying them and using
editing tools like CRISPR move those
genes basically into the genomes of
living elephant cells moving the
direction of eventually being able to
get a cell with the nucleus that is
basically woolly mammoth genome and then
getting that into a living Asian
elephants who can then give birth to
woolly mammoths obviously this go
through many steps and then move from
there through the standard
reintroduction techniques of wildlife
conservation to get the woolly mammoths
up to a population that is
self-sustaining as enough genetic
variability that they will not get into
an in breeding bottleneck and start the
process of reintroducing them to their
wild which was the far north well
there's not a lot of people so they do
be able to perhaps prosper pretty well
and eventually the rest of that story is
lowly mammoths could be part of the
revival of what used to be called the
mammoth step which is the grasslands of
the far north that was once the largest
biome on earth but when humans got
through all of that biome and killed off
all the large megafauna except for the
musk ox that grassland turned into
tundra and boreal forests
mammoths would be helpful as we bring
back the various grazers the far north
like the musk ox and maybe the woolly
mammoth woolly rhinoceros of the
mammoths are good as elephants were good
all over the world everybody had had
elephants uh and what they're good at is
knocking
trees and knocking down trees is good
because it turns a closed canopy forest
into a mosaic and a mosaic ecologically
is a much richer environment for all
kinds of species as we see in parts of
Africa that have these animals and the
Far North could be like the Serengeti is
now so let's take a while but we'll
probably do it since to those people who
are feel fearful of some of what they
perceive as implications of this to
someone who might say for instance we
couldn't have predicted when we were
eliminating these species or we didn't
predict the downstream effects how can
we be confident in predicting the the
consequences of reintroducing say
megafauna like the woolly mammoth what
what is the response to that well that
that a statement that analysis is
usually based on the you see this also
with the climate yeah this is a system
so complex that we don't understand it
and if you screw around with a complex
system you will have unintended
consequences that you'll just hate and
if that approach were completely adopted
there would be no human medicine because
for sure the human body is a very
complex system of which we have at best
partial knowledge but we screw around
with it all the time and that's why I
and any number of people are still alive
as medical interventions were made that
we you know had reason to think might
work out and thanks to a lot of science
or a lot of time and a lot of failures
they do work out so what you do with a
complex system you don't completely
understand as you tweak it and see what
the tweak does and tweaking is good
because it's probably not going to cause
some major change it would cause a small
local change you can see how it works
and ecology is not a predictive science
but it is a great observation
science and so like with the human body
these experiments see what happens and
then build on your successes and work
around your failures kind of normal and
they should say I'm taking a devil's
advocate position
there are also some there are
observational data sets that you can
pull from that don't involve genetic
rescue incorporating something like
CRISPR but say the reintroduction of
wolves to certain parts of Yellowstone
and how that affected say elk or deer
populations which affected grazing which
affected ultimately the paths of rivers
and so on it means fascinating there's
some really engaging video video that
that discusses that now is the woolly
mammoth a how much of the interest in
the woolly mammoth specifically is about
an input that has a very strong output
say ecologically versus just a
fascination with the woolly mammoth
there's no end of fascination of the
woolly mammoth because there's no end of
fascination with elephants as there will
should be these are just anybody has
really spent time with elephants small
falls in love with elephants and in Asia
the Asian elephants have been you know a
partially domesticated animal for a long
time and the fact that it is still
endured beside along with the fact that
about a hundred people are killed by
elephants in Asia every year um suggests
that you know not only they useful they
are loved in Africa they don't kill
people quite as much but there's a
certain amount of death and destruction
that happens with them there so let's
have an open mind about that there's
downsides as well as upsides for having
an elephant in your life but of humans
and elephants who've lived together for
a long time and mostly we know how to do
that
and their safest for themselves
and for us when they are in wilderness
is that they pretty much own and the the
far north the Arctic and subarctic
regions would be swell for that in terms
of woolly mammoth I think I went so
astray from your question I lost track
of what it was oh that's okay the the
question was how much of it was a
strategic decision for the impact the
woolly mammoth could have versus a
personal interest or passion for the
woolly mammoth that is unrelated to its
impact if reintroduced well here's a a
scale issue here which as a lifelong
conservationist I'm concerned about
which is we hear about biodiversity a
lot but I want to reintroduce the idea
of bio abundance and one of the
important plants it's being brought back
genetically is the American chestnut
which used to be one quarter of all the
trees in the eastern deciduous forest
there where you are and then a blight
came along from Asia that killed them
basically they're there evolutionarily
still around but ecologically they're
extinct but a workaround is found to
make American chestnuts that are now
completely plate proof and those are
being bred up and because they're a food
plant wheat chestnuts roasting on the
open fire they are going through the
government regulation process but should
be they're getting back into the wild
already and what they will do is not
just introduce one tiny element of
biodiversity the eastern forest they
will introduce food that comes raining
down sweet nuts that everybody eats
including humans and when they all died
off the animals that lived on those nuts
had to start making do with acorns which
happened only from time to time and
they're bitter so the the richness of
the eastern
tourists will be made much more bio
abundant as these trees come back the
same is true as you mentioned with bring
wolves back to Yellowstone the same is
very much true bringing beavers back to
Scotland and now to England
they've been reintroduced in Sweden and
they are what are called ecosystem
engineers that make the ponds that cut
down some of the trees that make a whole
rich environment for lots of other
species along with themselves and I
would like to everybody who's been on
safari in Africa whether in south africa
or Kenya Tanzania has had an experience
of wildlife on land where my god there's
hippos in giraffes rhinos and lions and
elephants and a a lot of big animals
moving around and dealing with one
another wildebeest and you know huge
herds like American bison used to be in
the US and the whole world was like that
it's just a remnant in Africa of what
the entire world was like I think a
whole lot of the world can be that again
with the large animals um and that's
sort of my long-term goal as it happens
one of the largest of the land animals
is woolly mammoth and looks like they're
relatively straightforward one to bring
back so there you have it one big
animals amethyst good place to start
thank you that's extremely helpful and
I'd love to expand from that to a
discussion of for lack of a better term
environmentalism in general and this is
a quote feel free to correct it because
often quotes are missed quotes but his
that's you Stewart his own big idea is
that the best approach to the issues he
discusses his pragmatism he flushes it
out by example rather than by discussing
its philosophical defense by John Dewey
or well James he reckons it as an
engineer
approach accepting whatever gets results
for environmentalists he suggests it
means not a shift in ideology but
discarding ideology completely and the
part that grabbed my attention here is
the it means not a shift in ideology but
discarding ideologically ideology
completely I was wondering if you could
talk a bit about that and what you mean
by it
I was part of the creation I guess of
so-called modern environmental movement
in the 60s and 70s and a couple of
things got brought into the
environmental movement kind of by
proximity and osmosis so there was a
leftist perspective that came in from
the new left at the time and so a lot of
the environmental movement was sort of
knee-jerk anti-corporate anti-business
and there's a lot of romanticism that
came from the hippies back to the land
and a lot of that kind of stuff in that
romanticism and turned into a certain
amount of anti technology and even anti
science to be one was nature is to you
know dissolve yourself in the nature
that is already there and don't
with it in any kind of intervention or
any kind of a reliance on technology was
regarded as a quote techno fix and
therefore contemptible that set of
framings
kind of gotten sat in concrete and
greatly outlived their usefulness and
started to get away so in 2010 I came
out with a book it was basically about
the rise of equal pragmatism that I
called whole earth discipline and it was
looking at things that I thought
looked like environmentalists just had
wrong
we had wrong that genetic engineering
was a bad thing in agriculture GMOs were
thought to be bad starting with the
Friends of the Earth and and spreading
from there I saw how that happened at
the time a nuclear was thought to be bad
and when climate change came along and
it was shortest cut to being able to
really really reduce the emissions of
greenhouse gases
it was discounted for reason it's left
over from an earlier time cities were
taken as the problem rather than a
solution but you look at the demographic
cities are the solution that is the
greenest thing that humans do and
geoengineering of intervening in the
climate directly to buy ourselves more
time to cut counter emissions was taken
to some kind of profound abomination and
as Al Gore told me brand you want to
experiment with the whole planet don't
do it well you know again this is like
we were saying about what we do at
ecosystems you tweak things and see what
works and then go in the direction of
what works and avoid what is not working
so I think the environmental movement to
the extent that it even be called a
single thing anymore is catching up to
the real world and that's taking a whole
lot longer than I would have liked but I
think reality especially in terms of
climate is going to keep hammering us
well I'd it seems to me that looking at
the projects you're currently involved
with looking at the projects that you've
been involved with you're very good at
enlisting the help and collaboration of
other people and I I asked Kevin Kelley
if there
particular questions or topics or facets
of your life that might be fun to
explore and one one of the bullets that
came back was very few humans have ever
turned down a request by Stewart how is
he so persuasive and I'll just I'll
leave it at that I I don't know how to
how to really dig into that so I can try
but let me just keep it general why does
why does Kevin have that perception of
you and why are you if that's the case
it's so effectively persuasive do you
think I could knows I don't ask that
much basically I invite people to give
these seminars about long term thinking
and it's kind of like being invited to
give a TED talk it's not that hard to
say yes because you'll get a nice
audience for being invited to be on the
show I do run into a fair amount of
people who feel one form or another of
kind of gratitude and maybe admiration
or the Whole Earth Catalog back in the
day and so a number of years ago when I
asked craig venter to give a cell talk I
was surprised to hear him sort of
leaping and into saying yes it turned
out he's of a generation who got his
twig bent by the Whole Earth Catalog and
uh you know felt like he felt good about
pay back so certain amount goes with
that other stuff has to do with just
being around and kind of being public
for decade after decade you get kind of
known and and recognized enough where
you don't sort of have to establish your
bona fides over time because that's
already been done and I think it's more
profound than that well at the same time
though I could say you've been in the
public
and met many many many many many people
interacted with a huge group of
individuals when most people have that
much interaction over a long period of
time you sometimes you make mistakes
maybe people meet you on a bad day you
don't seem to have and this is maybe a
strong wording but you don't seem to
have any known enemies if that makes
sense I've never heard someone attack
you and maybe that's just because I
haven't come across it why do you think
why do you think that's the case and
even if that isn't the case why is that
the perception I'm not powerful or rich
so you know the enemies that go with a
position of power there's nothing to
resist and the resentment that goes with
this kind of wealth is not there either
I've certainly had people who strongly
opposed me on certain things sometimes
publicly mostly I think that my
successes have been public and my
failures have been private so from the
outside it looks like lots of good
things can you I don't really know yeah
I've not been associated I guess with
things that were later wish that I
hadn't been or the other people wish
that I had not been and you know so the
main politician that I've worked closely
with was Jerry Brown well neither he nor
I are suffering from his reputation in
that respect so my associations have
worked out very well and I guess I'm
lucky do you have any particular failure
that you could share which greatly
informed your life after you experienced
it or something that could be something
that set you up for later success or
just a failure that
taught you a lot in some way or another
um I failed to finish Ranger training in
the army and I quit partway through
after this sort of early getting into it
stuff Ranger training is much harder now
than it was then of Airborne training
jump training is pretty much the same
now that it was then but um it was five
weeks six weeks or something uh pretty
intense stuff and about halfway through
after having finished a 5-mile run part
and they saving myself from drowning in
32 degree water with weighed down with a
magician bags and all of that one day I
just quit and I think the what I told
myself was it was a January February and
Accord Benning which I think was south
nice and warm there's freezing cold and
order out in it and I was thinking I'm
not learning much it was so cold so that
was just stupid excuse I gave myself to
quit and what I and it's like all of
these intense know that your trainers
he'll do or don't sir any of those guys
do if you say I don't want to do this
anymore you were gone in about 30
seconds which is the right thing to do
and so what I learned from that is don't
quit anything for a snap decision reason
I quit lots of stuff including many
successes but I don't do it on a snap
decision anymore
can you think of a let's see a project
or anything that you were involved with
later where you had the impulse to quit
and what was behind it and then what you
did instead I'm making noise trying to
avoid radio silence your voice ponder if
there's something I wanted I could also
I could also come back to that
by sometime if you like sure list by
time because I'm not getting anything
immediate alright so I'm gonna buy time
since we were talking about physical
training I to confirm one thing which is
your are you currently 78 is that right
correct okay and you do CrossFit twice a
week that's correct
all right now I guess to two questions
related to CrossFit one is because you
seem to thrive on variety and like you
mentioned you get bored of say
snowboards it's up down up down up down
what what appeals to you about CrossFit
number one and the number two do you
have any favorite exercises or workouts
well good god
well the main in relation to getting
bored a wonderful thing about CrossFit
it for me among other things is that
it's a different set of exercises that
you encounter every single time so I've
been going for two and a half years now
and I do not you know look online to see
what the workout is going to be I show
up and I have my jump rope and I'm going
to do whatever is there that day and
it's always different
and that plus because you're doing it
with other people in a competitive mode
there's a social aspect to it and
there's going to be a different group of
people in the two days a week I go some
of the same you know hiya Nick hi Casey
uh and some that are different and um
competitive aspect that you're going
against time and keeping score helps
keep it interesting it's a very
impressive product a genius program in
terms of getting rid a lot of the
spurious stuff of gyms so there's no
machines there's no mirrors when there
are growing machines but that's it um
there's free weight work the free weight
work is
only straightforward strengthen at the
coordination to manage freeways you
don't have a machine doing the managing
part for you and I made a huge
difference for me I started it at 75 Oh
suddenly I was within a few months 30
pounds lighter and I'm in 157 pounds now
which is the weight I was when I started
Whole Earth Catalog at the age of 30 and
and then you stand different as you know
when you work out and I pick one of the
things I learned to appreciate in the
military was being able to stand like
you mean it stand like you mean it
you've got to be fit and that just makes
all the difference my own sense is that
I certainly for males and maybe for
anybody um being as having a certain
amount of fitness and strength makes you
proud and being proud is the most
reliable source of happiness that I know
said the CrossFit is fascinating to me
on many different levels and well I had
my first CrossFit workout in 99 or 2000
I once it was around 2000 in Mountain
View at a health Gracie Jiu Jitsu
Academy where a number of the guys were
going to Santa Cruz to train with a
bunch of the original crossfit crew and
it's morphed a lot over time but at i
remember in that year and maybe the year
after how many people talked about how
there was no demand for yet another
group exercise program yeah it made me
think of how Starbucks was turned down
by many many many many many different
investors who said
really another coffee chain nobody needs
that and this leads me to want to ask
you about and I would love for you to
describe it a little bit for people who
are not familiar with it you mentioned a
name earlier on which was Doug Engelbart
and you were present for what has been
called the mother of all demos and I'd
look for you to describe for people what
that was and what the experience and
feeling was for you and other people in
the room because what I don't know
because I haven't read much about it is
if if people realized the implications
of what they were witnessing so if you
could kind of take it from here and tell
us the story that would be great yeah so
beginning with Starbucks and CrossFit
the difference between a good idea and
good execution or even a bad idea and
good execution the execution on CrossFit
was impeccable and you being there as a
starter business impressive the there's
a nice book on it by JC Hertz called
learning to breathe fire which pretty
much tells the story of how CrossFit
came about and the the title refers to
that something I saw in the military and
learned to appreciate there when I would
talk basic training which is these you
can take people and push them beyond
I'll get them in a situation where they
go beyond their expectations what
they're capable of the world opens up to
them and that's one of the things that
we did with basic training and I would
see these trainees come in from Brooklyn
and so on and we would push them and
they would discover that there was so
much more that they could do with their
bodies and under certain circumstances
with their minds and they thought and
and then they and they they started to
grow toward infinity with that
realization
so CrossFit does that for a lot of
people it's quite intense and that
intensity is you know what you realize
you can do stuff that didn't think you
could do then things open up so the
mother of all demos was a 1969 old joint
computer conference and this was a
demonstration where a group at SR I that
I got to be part of as a sort of a
advisor and filmer um showed the results
of about three or four years of work
doing what doe getting a book called
automatic human intellect and it was
using mainframe and many computer
capabilities to do interactive text
windows they developed his leading
engineer Bill English developed to the
mouse and he gave a demo it was about an
hour and a half long in San Francisco
that is the greatest high-wire act
you've ever seen because they had
developed the computer that was running
the demo was not in San Francisco it was
30 miles south in Menlo Park and Bill
English had developed the microwave
capability to get the data flowing back
and forth between San Francisco and
Menlo Park so the computer generated
demo was was happening well that was a
very tin cans and string kind of
connection and so getting it to a you
know the edge of capability and then
maintaining it for an hour and a half
it's astonishing in its own right so
bill English or bill English was in the
room and was in Doug Engelbart's ear he
is on the stage and also on the
projected screen and his face is being
cut in and out of the
you visuals that he is working you
showing how you can create text change
text make various files move the files
around connect them to other people
he's showing the mouse he's showing a
keyboard he developed it so one-handed
keyboard and all of the time that he's
going through his spiel which we had
rehearse once or twice but it was
basically him just telling a play out of
the work that he and the team had been
developing for three or four years it
was hanging over the Raggedy edge the
whole time bill bill would whisper into
his ear we lost signal professional Park
make it for a while and and Doug we just
launched into a summon comb iums for the
people that he worked with and holding
forth on that while it was computer came
back up it really was an awesome demo I
was not in the room I was in Menlo Park
filming that parts of the action and
hands on keyboards and what was on the
screen stuff like that so at the end of
it you know I was just hearing the voice
of a person was in communication with
Bill English who was in communication
with Doug on the stage and everything
kind of wound down and and we're looking
around and said over yeah it's over well
did they like it or just a second check
and turns out the in the room it had
been a standing ovation and minds blown
and Alan Kay redirecting his entire
career and various people getting
completely knocked out and blown away by
it all but down in Menlo Park it was
Patrick came back um yeah apparently
they liked it good night everybody we
just we just all wandered home oh wow
this is another day in the office let's
go get some pizza thank God it's over
yeah basically you know we'd worked hard
and it's done now shoo
all right so I I want to mention one
thing about just to just to come back
I'll feel I feel a duty just to say one
more thing about CrossFit which is crop
there are a lot of incredible things and
benefits associated with CrossFit I
think there is a risk that people should
be aware of which is the ideology of our
way is the only way so there is a bit of
a a culture of intolerance around some
people who practice CrossFit and so I
would just caution people to be aware of
that so they don't develop a model a
myopic approach to fitness and I know a
lot of people who were involved with
CrossFit but I've also for instance
after one podcast I did and that the
headline of which was the good the bad
and the ugly of CrossFit had the founder
of CrossFit reach out to schedule a
phone call and I thought it was going to
be because the podcast was very
complementary that it would be a
conversation about maybe doing something
on the podcast or something else and
instead it was this very sort of
threatening call because of the headline
even though they had not listened to the
audio so I would just caution people
about anything that paints a very
black-and-white picture that is us
versus them that would just be my
cautionary tale on the mother of all
demos and moving back into tech a little
bit though I would love to talk about
the expression information wants to be
free can you comment on this phrase that
is attributed to you information wants
to be free
and also if it is the entire quote I've
read that it is not so if you could
elaborate on that a bit I would
certainly love to
oh it keeps coming up from time to time
because there is a paradox out there of
information especially on the web just
swarming around and you know should
there be paywalls
for scientific journals and my feeling
and that is there should not by the way
but you can see why
Elsevier and other organizations they
have paywalls about scientific journals
are reluctant to take them down because
they are extremely your immunity or for
those organizations but I think they are
bad for science so that's a current
application of this particular argument
of the statement I made goes back to
1984 when Kevin Kelly and I am Ryan
Phelan organized a thing called a
hackers conference it turned out to be
the first hackers conference that
particular thing is carried on year to
year since then and one of the people
who came to the hackers conference was
Steve Wozniak along with a lot of the
great hackers at the time and leave
helsing Stein and and you know the best
reporter all of that material John
Markoff was there and Aniyah and it's
great there's a good video on it you can
find online but in the course of it
there were a lot of kind of public
discussions and the issues at the time
being talked about one of them was
freeware shareware and regular
commercial products and Steve Wozniak
was making the point that and
copy-protection was a big question that
was going on around because
copy-protection would be put on
softwares he couldn't easily copy it and
give it to your friends but on the other
hand the capri Protection and made it
much less convenient to use as a tool
and that was a real debate as Steve
Wozniak was saying quite right well
engineer puts a couple years work into
one of these things he or she was mostly
in those days should get some kind of
remuneration so it needs to be
commercial and I I apparently replied
that's right information does want to be
expensive but information also wants to
be free and as it gets easier and easier
to copy anything that's digital and
distributed equally easily that debate
is going to go on forever that the
information wants to be free and it
wants to be expensive and information
everybody knew the information should be
expensive that was a standard commercial
model but the things that digital
capabilities were bringing was that
there could be vast quantities of
information moving around freely so
information wants to be free became kind
of a a slogan or a motto or something at
the time a bumper sticker shortcut to
dealing with a large phenomenon that was
happening but the rest of it really was
and information wants to be expensive
and that relationship is not
contradictory it's paradoxical in the
sense that the more the one the more the
other and the more information wants to
be free Emma wants to be expensive
because there's that many more values to
accrue to very large audiences etc and
it's a I think a debate which is
permanent it's kind of like a debate
itself around the term hackers a hacker
a good guy or or a criminal and the
answer is both and information does will
continue to be a source of major
commercial activity and a source of huge
free available stuff so you know my rule
on Twitter is when I link to something I
only like to stuff that's not behind
paywalls you can go look at itself
and probably once you get there that
source will show you whatever I like to
and they'll beg you to subscribe and pay
for their service and you might do that
yeah I was mystified recently I'm not
gonna mention the outlet because I might
actually get it wrong that it was a site
mainstream scientific publication that
was only it was promoting articles in
its Twitter account and they were all
behind a paywall
drove me nuts
because I said it's tricky I mean you
have publications like New Scientist
which is not really a strict scientific
publication is very good publication but
they pay well all their stuff and as a
result I think they have a much smaller
audience then things that look like
they'll be want to be widely read by the
public from nature or science magazine
often get out from behind the paywall
and that's good for science is good for
public understanding of science I think
it's ultimately good for the
publications because people realize
there's lots more good stuff where that
one came from well no exactly I mean if
you're trying to get someone hooked on a
drug whether that is a pharmaceutical or
really good information in a curated and
edited magazine you it's it behooves you
to give them a sample if it's really
good enough to be addictive so if you
have a social account where you're only
sharing things behind a paywall there's
no conceivable sort of user behavior
that I can think of where they go click
on a headline expecting to read an
article they don't get the article and
then they're asked to pay for it so by
and large not every now and then you
know you're so desperate see as you pay
the twenty nine ninety five or whatever
it is to see the thing but you're you
know you're angry I would love to I
suppose is actually perhaps a good segue
from from angry or frustrated a lot of
people suffer from clutter and I have
heard that even at the the height of
paper so before most things or many
things are digitized
that you had a completely clean desk and
that that is also true of your inbox and
did you hear that I don't to incriminate
anybody if it's not true do it what
happened is that is that not true is
that not accurate all right well though
we can we can skip that if it's not
accurate but if you have any
organizational rules or principles that
help you to keep all your life in order
or projects in order maybe that's a
graceful lateral move from what I guess
is incorrect yeah I think whatever
systems they use or or half crap and I
have been rewarded for not getting rid
of stuff which is that the guy who's
actually suffering from most amount by
the way is John Markoff because he's a
guy you took on trying to write a
biography of me in so it's a fun book
project where I get to sort of help in
the research but I don't have to do any
of the work but the poor guy is
overloaded with material because I plant
actually relatively stable and
continuous life in the Bay Area and so
my interesting stuff I just threw into
boxes and there's now I gather 70 linear
feet at Stanford and there are
archivists and they've got probably
another hundred plus feet of my papers
yet to come notebooks that I kept every
day every day but I've written in since
I was in college and all that stuff so
having enough storage based it's really
interesting stuff with the remote idea
might be eventually interesting go back
to turned out which is you know it's a
cluttering not a decluttering move
decluttering move is to get the hell rid
of it anyway it gives poor John
to work with and I think of a result
there is is that you'll be able to tell
a more accurate and probably less
interesting story of me whereas if there
was none of that stuff it would all be
hearsay and hearsay is way more
interesting than real things if if you
are teaching a let's say a Freshman
Seminar in college
Stanford wherever you could take your
pick Berkeley it doesn't matter you
could teach anything you wanted you
could have a class size of any size what
would you teach and why I don't think
Western Civ is taught anymore it would
be probably called global Civ
but it was a required course freshman
year and 56 at Stanford for me and it's
a great thing to begin a college
undergraduate education with a sort of
the overview of civilizations so far and
there was also a very good course on
comparative religion taught by Frederick
Spielberg that I took and those two
things are framing that I would love to
see more open I don't think I'm
qualified to teach a thing like that but
any person who takes on teaching
something like that is you've got some
wonderful research to do and you have a
concept like big history now big history
is basically everything from the Big
Bang to this week I'll put together in
one somewhat coherent narrative and
that's that's the kind of thing I think
is helpful to have out there I'm not a
very good teacher
I can occasionally give an OK lecture
but teaching um is a real talent as well
as skill and I have neither the talent
nor the skill
well let's just pretend though that you
had the talent and the skill but as you
put it you weren't qualified to teach
Western civilization but that if someone
were to they would have some wonderful
research to do let's just pretend that
say Stanford reaches out to you at some
point after this podcast and they say
great news we would be honored if you
would teach a class on Western
civilization when you have time to
prepare and they caught you in a moment
of weakness so you agreed if you had say
a few months to prepare for that
what would you how would you go about
researching it
what would you read who would you talk
to what would your approach be well Tim
this brings up another issue that I
think not so many of your guests get
into which is at the age of 78 how many
months do I have to prepare anything
my health is great but you know the
actuarial tables are pretty clear and I
find myself not taking on long term
commitments as much there's a book I'd
love to do would be called how to be
rich well and that would take three or
four years of serious research and
probably two years of writing and that's
not actually what I want to do at the
age of 78 is who knows how much time so
Kevin Kelley I just probably put it to
you when he's put it to various people
in similar mode which is that we both
discovered that it's you move from
project project in your life the
projects that look like they're I mean
start projects all the time
most of them don't take but the ones
that take that you find that you
continue to be interested in they're
starting to be enough other people
interested in that the thing kind of
makes circuit with the world are
starting to come to life to follow
through on it and make it really come to
pass and be a thing in the world it's
going to take about five years give or
take and
at various times in your life you have a
sense of how many five years it's left
you might have and once you get into
your 70s that becomes a number of
fingers on the one hand kind of thing so
one is not quite as oh yeah I guess I'll
really take on that huge five-year
commitment all that I may not live to
finish just given the way the statistics
fall so that's a different answer to
your question but there's there's very
good stuff in that line from Oliver
Sacks
in his last year when he was writing
like May had the whole time that he knew
he was dying and I'm right at all but I
saw glimpses of it he would say things
like there's some subjects I find him
not interested in anymore because I
really can't do anything about them such
as climate change and you know stages of
life is a life extension folks are
working away but meanwhile mostly we're
working with a finite resource here and
so that's part of life management is
what you're doing with the time you've
got Kevin Kelley has a clock on his on
his computer that it's counting down to
the day dies according to the current
actuarial tables you notice how many
hours more he's going to live
accordingly how do you choose your
problem how do you choose your
commitment now how do you filter what to
say yes to or what to say no to well
there's a shift I think in most people's
careers that actually are having a
career if it involves responding to
opportunities and an early career the
the algorithm is yes and less no and
it's just you get invited to do
something of course probably so you say
yes and they find out if it's actually
maybe not such a good idea
but at a certain point that
flips into no unless yes and so I get
invited to give a talk now it's pretty
much no unless yes I'm not trying to
build a career there's a short amount of
work and travel and updating the slides
it over the hell it maybe and there's
other things I want to put my time on
but people who don't make that shift
you'll find them get into a kind of a
crazy point maybe you've been there of
trying to move ahead on every
opportunity that presents itself and
they're all good but in combination they
are absolutely lethal trying to take
them on more than the right number but
at the same time so and then you know
you know unless yes the criteria for
saying yes changed at the beginning
they're pretty relaxed and then they get
more and more constrained as time goes
by Cece mentioned a word that I want to
grab on to which is is finite and there
is a book that has in the last two years
it's very it's very odd maybe it's
selective attention kind of like when
you buy say a new jacket or a new car
and suddenly it seems like everyone is
wearing the same jacket or driving the
same car chances are it hasn't happened
overnight you just have more attention
towards it but there's a book there's a
book that originally came to my
attention through Jane McGonigal who's
brilliant and amazing and it's and this
was about two years ago and it has
increasingly been sort of entering my
life from different directions and that
is James Peake Arce's finite and
infinite games oh good so I hope could
you please tell people about this book
and how it has affected your thinking
or just the principal or the the
distinction between a finite and an
infinite game I got really interested in
games back in the early 70s and in fact
organized the thing called the new games
tournament and the idea I had there was
actually began with my mentor at the
time of psychologist biologist
anthropologist named Gregory Bateson and
some reason we were talking about theory
of games and the way it was being played
out and in terms of the nuclear standoff
at the Cold War
he said theory games is is brilliant he
actually knew Jonathan Hyman who came up
with it and he said the problem of the
theory of games is it doesn't have a
theory about how you changed the rules
of a game yeah I thought that was a
profound thing to say found thing to
ponder and maybe act on and then I got
myself noticing the way I as a kid
played games and the way kids in general
play games if they're not carted off to
little week and soccer practice and all
that stuff is that when they play games
they're changing the rules all the time
and so stickball is sort of a version of
baseball that depends entirely on how
many people you've got in the street and
the nature of the street or you're going
to be able to use is first base stuff
like that and kids are more easily bored
than anybody and so they'll be playing a
game and it's going along and it gets
kind of boring into somebody says you
know what if we pay volleyball or
instead of the the way you usually play
it we play it where let's see how long
we can go usually the usual rules only
the deal is I'll see how long we can go
before the ball hits the ground and it
turns from a competitive into a
collaborative game so a set of new games
tournament is a public place where
a bunch of strange games would be
provided I provided a 6-foot high earth
ball that people invented various games
around this big push ball that crowds
people can interact with we had a we got
a huge ship saucer and a head tug of war
that went across a kind of a canyon
where was a 300 foot ship saucer and a
couple hundred people on each side and
there was a woman starts oh I had a
starter pistol and you had to both sides
had to stand off ten feet away from the
rope fire the pistol he goes run to the
rope and start pulling and of course the
point across the canyon so the team
that's starting to lose are finding
themselves dangling over this that was
really just roll but there dangling in
space and then stick by Stander's would
feel sorry for them and then join the
team that was about to lose and help
pull the other direction and those guys
would start to lose and bystanders would
help them I'm gonna go back and forth
this kind of emergent property of kind
of freely shaping games really really
interested me so this is and we had a
number of such things or I am band heard
a few games some of them were semi
violent and would be an example of a
semi violent one that was called
slaughter I felt this for the war
resisters League this during the
resistance to Vietnam war resisters week
knew that I was doing public events and
they asked me like the troops festival I
asked me what I do a public event for
them so there's an ex-military guy who's
being asked to these people who want
nothing to do in the military view that
advise them on what kind of event to
have and I said well you guys need a war
in the worst way and but it can be war
in your terms and so we came up with a
series of public events that we did at
various campuses in the Bay Area that
had among other things some kind of
warlike games and when I invented was
called slaughter
that's what I knew from hanging out with
American Indians and others is that
really physical games involve both sexes
um is is really good for young people
because you get to do a lot of kind of
we're not allowed to say grab-ass now
but it it's physical sweaty
interaction that is not explicitly
sexual but everything is sexual at that
age and so it's like dancing only
competitively and in a little more free
form so the game I invented for these
were sisters who I thought were not in
their bodies sufficiently or probably
getting laid enough that this game would
involve very very physical interaction
and what we did was we get a pretty
large wrestling mat maybe 20 feet by 20
feet and that was played on your knees
because one of the things that realized
is if people standing up can take their
interactions are too violent and pulling
down hurts and so on and the deal was
that there's two teams and be shirts or
non shirts or socks or non socks or
whatever and they're on their knees and
there's a starter gun and they go at
each other and the deal is to you can
kill the other players by wrestling them
off of the edge of the mat and at the
slaughter and you know immediately
people started coming up with all sorts
of strategies teaming up and trying to
stay out of the fray and lasting longer
and you know various things you can
imagine people doing and the deal is
once any part of your body goes over the
edge of the mat you're dead and you turn
into a referee and so the people who
have been killed immediately out there
saying doctor out on tap tap you got to
leave and I threw in some other
complications of medicine balls it had
to be put in baskets and things like
that so it had the advantage of being
intensely physical because people really
are having to grab and rustle each other
and and move them from to the edge of
the mat and simultaneously deal with
defending a basket and moving their ball
into the other team's basket where is it
now and there was overwhelm intensity an
overwhelmed that is ideal because you
get out of your body of that much
intensity and that many things to think
about it once so that was smaller and
what was the did you observe any
particular effects on the group from
playing this game aside fed loved it
they loved they of course these were
resistors were dying to have a physical
combat and in a way that clearly was you
know not killing anybody is not even
hurting anybody we had t-shirts said
play hard play fair nobody hurt and in a
way that that was the better thing than
war is a kind of competitive situation
when you play hard play power play hard
play fair nobody heard so it worked out
well
and all this is leading up to why a book
called
finite and infinite games so I think the
fundamental interest is gamification
thinking of things in game terms
designing things and game terms is one
of the profound things civilization has
done for a very long time and it's a way
of organizing physical and mental
behavior often in combination that is
just wonderful and the along with the
James speakers book the other book is
homo Luden's
by a poisoner and homo Luden's basically
says man the player of games is is what
we do well here first takes apart the
games
that are win-lose like collections to
the games that are gone forever which is
democracy and you need them both and
within any election you're everybody's
got to go by the rules that they've
agreed to but within democracy
you're always looking for okay we got a
problem with the rules or we're bored
with the rules
what's an improvement that we can make
and the infinite game is the infinite
improvement of the games we play
and that's civilization story right now
in democracy where you know thinking
about should we change the rule about
electoral college versus popular vote
and we're talking about changing the
rules of how to prevent gerrymandering
from being such a disorder of the
electoral process and so on I think the
more people are comfortable with the
idea of constantly improving the games
we play and the techniques of doing that
the freedom to do that in the sense that
it goes on indefinitely
the better off we are and this is horse
might say - playing playing with the
rules not just within the rules and yeah
the but you've got the points he makes
is you know within a game there's a
boundary there's going to be rules
players of the game need to agree on the
rules and you see kids do this all the
time that you know they play a game sort
of not so interesting somebody says well
let's do it Sonne so wait what that's
not there's an argument and all their
argument okay we'll try it that way and
and if it works and they like it then
they'll keep it and on it goes so
there's there's the game and then
there's the argument in that combination
is part of the story is the is the
contrast that you've I believe you've
made before between goals and
ways related to the all of this or is it
maybe a separate topic that I'd still
nonetheless love to hear you expand on a
bit in this yeah it whether it's related
to any of your projects right the Whole
Earth Catalog
or anything else I've read that you know
goals are not that interesting to you
but pathways are and I would be as
someone who has traditionally been very
goal focused but has in recent years
changed my thinking about how I select
projects to be maybe less explicitly
singularly goal focused I would love to
hear your distinction between the two
goals and pathways this comes down to a
lot of the career theories that one one
here is out there follow your passion
figure out what you want to do in life
major in it get a graduate degree in it
and to go do it that ain't really worked
for people who have a clear idea that
they want to be an X but I kind of buy
that that's only for some people a lot
of us have no idea what we want to be or
it turns out here early I wanted to be a
firefighter I fought a forest fire
briefly in Michigan when I was young and
I was going to go to the University of
Idaho Idaho and Moscow
and go ahead and get a PhD in
firefighting unfortunately I had a
teacher in prep school who said you know
you could go to someplace else like
Stanford for your undergraduate degree
and then if you want to get a PhD in
firefighting go to Idaho that hadn't
really occurred to me so you know he
saved me from probably a pretty limited
fate of when the University of
versus Stanford in that case which I had
the option to both it's I got to prep
school and then to college and realize
that nearly everybody there was smarter
and more capable than me and a lot of
them knew exactly what they were
planning to do they were going to be
lawyers and biologists and physicists
and whatnot and I adopted my older
brother who'd gone to Stanford Mike had
gone there eight years before me and he
knew some of the best teachers there
because he stumbled into them or heard
about them he said the way to get the
best out of college is do you find out
what really good teachers are and then
get a major that limits you the minimum
and then go to all the good teachers so
I did that and one of the things that
got for me was a sort of a wider range
of mini expertise and I would have
gotten otherwise and then and then when
I got out of Stanford I started taking
courses at the San Francisco Art
Institute in San Francisco State College
and various skills that I wanted to get
and design and in photography among
other things and so by the time I was 22
he probably had eight different ways I
could have made a living the skills that
I had acquired from being a logger
choker setter to being an infantry
officer to being a field biologist to
being a commercial photographer and
various other things um most of those
things I did not do in fact the things
that I had trained to do the only one
that really played out was uh you know
six or eight years later when I started
the Whole Earth Catalog I had taken some
courses in writing and in magazine
design actually way the hell back at
Stanford and so when I wanted to start
what was a
magazine on Earth Catalog I ignored the
advice had been told which it takes a
million dollars to start a magazine and
I started it with ten or twenty thousand
dollars and I had the skills so you know
the general rule there is just keep on
acquiring skills and they way they add
up lets you do things that turn up you
discover you really wanted to do you did
not know that before but now you can do
it mm-hmm this that's that is when I hae
mentioned that I had changed how I was
approaching choosing projects it's
actually very similar in the sense that
Scott Adam this creator of Dilbert
refers refers to I suppose in place of
pathways he would talk about systems
thinking which is in some ways a little
confusing but effectively choosing
projects based on the skills and
relationships that you develop so that
even if said project fails over time you
are accumulating skills and
relationships so that when like you said
an opportunity presents itself that you
couldn't possibly have foreseen and
pegged as a goal as an objective or a
goal say three years before you are ripe
to take advantage of so I I I'm sorry go
ahead
that's it so I we could talk for hours
but I want to be respectful of your time
and wrap up shortly the so you just
agreed with me and that's actually a
perfect segue because I you you agree
and then disagree and seem very flexible
in changing your viewpoints and changing
your mind and you do this publicly this
is uncommon in a lot of worlds
[Music]
I wish it were common especially in
politics yes so how did you how did you
develop this or what is the self-talk
that allows you to do that
so readily um I was trained as a
scientist as a biologist at Stanford
there was a relatively low requirement
major now as there's one of the reasons
I took it but I'll also knew I was
interested in biology quite seriously
and um think about it training is a as a
scientist is um science is the only news
it is going to keep changing and and you
will be taught something is probably the
case and then you learn often within a
year or so well actually yeah we were
wrong about that and the people who were
strong proponents of that have been
exposed to the results of the people who
thought they were probably wrong and it
turns out they were wrong and whether or
not they've admitted that everybody else
knows it and so let's move on and so
that moving on as a result of results as
a result of trying stuff experiments or
observation or whatever with various
hypotheses you start get used to the
idea that all your opinions are
hypotheses and some of them play out and
some don't but that as you say that's
not a standard mode of public discourse
so I think it's helpful for when
somebody changes their mind about
something to spread the word that you
know they're they're pleased now I'll I
realize lots of times somebody is going
to go from one crazy belief to another
and in the 60s and 70s we saw people buy
into a lot of mystical frameworks and
gurus and whatnot and they would move
from one to the other but then I think
you can go up a level and
and suggest well if you're moving from
guru aid a guru be and then to guru see
does that suggest that maybe for you
gurus are a waste of time and say oh
there's various levels of being wrong
and acknowledging it and deciding what
to do about that in some cases you don't
doubling down is the right thing to do
because you really think there is
something there even though at the first
round it doesn't look like it's for sure
there so you double down a few times and
and maybe if you get punished down is no
longer the right thing to do for you but
I think with politicians
I would love every politician to have
pretty good answers to the question of
sir or ma'am uh in the course of your
public service and thank you for doing
that
what are some things that you noticed
you were wrong about had to change your
mind about and tell us about that Anna
police say as I've always said I'm never
wrong you know not to waste your time
with them yeah it's God such an
important question what is given the
game no sir we're talking about if the
finite and infinite games and I don't
want to take us too far into political
land because it would be instantly dated
right now whatever we say politically so
it's gonna be out of date tomorrow right
so I want to focus more on the the game
the game that politicians have chose to
play what is no is it possible to be an
effective politician while still
answering that question
honestly I guess there are probably
examples of people who have answered
that honestly but then there are people
who answer it honestly and get labeled a
flip-flopper or whatever you might call
it and that's used as ammo against them
in say elections of various types
is well I think a shining example of
mind changing that we have in California
is Governor Jerry Brown and I was on his
personal staff and his first term back
when he was the youngest governor and
I've kept a little bit in touch with him
now that he's our oldest government I
remember so I would be part of the
entourage and we go to some public event
like space day or something like that I
helped initiate and organize and you
know there outside the event would be
the usual protesters but one thing or
another and uh I would find myself you
know trying to get Jerry and we're
almost late come on let's keep moving
and he would see the protesters and then
he would veer off and go over and talk
to them and we're rolling our eyes but
here's how you would talk to protesters
you go over to whoever it look like was
being a spokesman they had the loud
hailer or something and say oh glad
you're here what's on your mind and they
would start to say their trip they would
listen for a bit I'd say I think I got
it let me see if I got it and then he
would say back to them their stance
often better than they had stated and
even see them just melt because the
thing they wanted to have happen was for
him to be aware of their position and to
understand it and he just showed that
he'd done that and then they had the
further hope that since it was known
that Jerry occasionally changed his mind
and his policy on things that not only
had he earned their position
he might even adopt it at some point and
so he could always engage and defuse
opposition with the fact that he could
be persuaded out of a position that he
had publicly taken this made him of a he
was not a good speaker he's not a
charismatic character for the longest
time basically an introvert in public
life and yet that characteristic as much
as any other
um he did a lot of good policy is very
bright and eventually a very capable
politician but that characteristic I
think opened him up to a very successful
political career and I think he came
into it partly because he is kind of a
contrarian he likes to go against the
flow and um and this would be a case
where you know he was a son of you grew
up in a political family with Pat Brown
his father and there were things about
the way politics were done that he
didn't approve of that was one of them
so he just went against it and won big
now for somebody who's thinking of going
into politics which I would encourage
anybody to do Jerry Brown is one good
example the other to me most wonderful
example is Theodore Roosevelt and
there's a three-volume biography of
Theodore Theodore Roosevelt by an author
his name is escaping me that is totally
inspiring this is a an individual with
modest gifts who basically set out on
your kind of self-improvement project
early on he was kind of a weak kid uh he
was born to do money and got himself out
of the strictures of that you know
became a rancher out west and all the
rest of it and kept reinventing himself
and helped reinvent America in profound
ways that he wanted to take on his kind
of self project and also take on public
service in the way that he did so um you
know one of the campaigns these days is
to get more scientists and engineers
going into not just appointed politics
but elective politics and I'm all for it
I think it's what needs to happen is the
three book series by edmund morris
that's the one it's a beautifully
written beautifully researched and an
astounding
Jake all right that is on my immediate
shopping list if someone listening not
planning to go into politics does not
have let's assume it's someone who has
no scientific training so to speak of
like yours truly I do not I'm not
betraying scientist oh wow I don't know
I mean I'm not a formally trained
scientist in any case are there any
books that you would recommend that
people could use to help train
themselves to think more scientifically
and therefore be less hell-bent on
holding on to strong opinions when given
new information I'm just now but a very
good question and I'm I wish the hell I
had an immediate answer to it I mean
it's probably you know some of the
biographies of good scientists Edward o
Wilson wrote a rather wonderful memoir
called naturalist about his becoming one
of the great biologists of his time and
this is a guy who revolutionized the
field of biology
five or six times personally it was the
name again
it's called naturalist by Edward o
Wilson Edward o Wilson got it yeah and
who was one of my inspirations as a
biologist and that later got to know him
when we worked together on a couple of
projects and it was just you know
awesome to do that and this is a guy
who's won the privilege surprised twice
so you're pleased they're in the hands
of a very good writer
um writings by Freeman Dyson are
excellent on the house science actually
works they're mostly collections of
essays one of his books is called
infinite in all directions which is the
right kind of frame to have in relation
to the universe um and science can get
you there as it did for him uh
the Fineman surely you're joking mr.
Feynman I was gonna bring another yeah
those work very well because such a
great blow this was one of the great
science teachers as well as one of the
great scientists and sort of watching
him think oh it's just good across the
board yeah there's a fantastic
documentary I want to say it was Nova so
it's a old television program it's hard
to find but it's called the joy of
finding things out in in which phiman
talks about in many ways how his father
taught him how to think and how to
question authority and it's just
fantastic if people can track that down
also but surely you must be joking or
surely you're joking mr. Fineman is such
a wonderful read yep so ones like that
and it's a good question to keep going I
think you know ask ative of any people
of the science background you get on
your series here I will and lasts lasts
maybe second to last question I just
turned 40 recently which has led me to
think a lot about maybe rules I've set
for myself for trajectory and many other
things just to reassess it wasn't a
crisis of any type I feel good about it
but I'm trying to ponder many different
things what do you wish you knew at age
40 or is there any advice that you would
give me or a four year old of course you
know there's specifics be helpful but
anything you wish you knew or that you
would emphasize for me or someone who
just turned 40 I think there's still
plenty of time is another thing which
comes completely to mind at age 40 is a
yeah I think you may think it's no serve
it's all downhill from here
or there's only so much time left and
some of the things that go with I'm no
longer young and things are no longer
infinite and all directions that are
starting to be finite and all pressures
but uh there's plenty of time and to
some extent time compresses as your age
increases I remember when my mother was
in her 80s I said what's time like for
you and she said years like fenceposts
was just whipping whipping by and I
certainly feel that at 78 I feel like
I'm spending all my time clipping my
fingernails and going to get another
goddamn haircut
and yet the thing which expands as time
goes by which is you don't have to read
derive a lot of stuff uh from first
principles you've already got a number
of things squared away you've got a
number of friends you can count on
you've got a number of skills that you
can deploy and so when you do take on
something new it's not like when you
were 22 or you have to sort of create
the whole world to do it in you've got a
lot of skills and so in a way time is
compressed for you in terms of your
abilities and that will continue as long
as your brain functions and then that
dials down and then you're presumably
got to deal with how you're going to
deal with your sensations are still
pretty intense and value from them do
you have any last recommendations
thoughts or questions that you'd like to
leave with the people listening to this
or any room or any request or ask of the
people listening to this I keep running
into
versions of something we came across a
couple times in this discussion which is
people worrying about unintended
consequences of often of new
technologies or of you know some new
regime or practice whatever the hell it
may be and and then often it'll be in
the mode of Dodie MINIX
Laura that area because unintended
consequences will occur and I think the
mode should be well of course on
intended consequences will occur and
maybe it's even worse and this is a
newer version of defining your fears
think about what the consequences that
you're worried about our and meanwhile
with watch well the thing goes head and
tries repent and try it yourself and
watch for those things that you're
worried about and also watch for
surprises lots of unintended
consequences are surprising and then you
watch for ones that are surprisingly
good as well as ones they're
surprisingly bad as near as I can tell
in most cases you gotta kind of an even
split with the expectation that the ones
who are surprisingly good you can not
only stop worrying about the things you
were worried about associated with that
you can build on them and also the ones
that are surprisingly bad that may
indicate well okay that whole pathway is
not so good after all to shut it down or
are there workarounds and basically is
trying to flip from being fearful about
unintended consequences to being
welcoming about situations that might
have unintended consequences I love that
and it makes me think of on top of that
recognising that with everything you do
in almost every moment there are
unintended consequences at all times and
that it draws for me a parallel with and
I maybe missed repeating this but I
believe at one point I read about Andy
Grove and in his management approach
would recognize that whenever you
created an incentive you would
simultaneously create a perverse
incentive or an incentive to do things
that were undesirable right so perhaps
you're I'm making this up but you have
you create a commission structure for
people to who bring in a certain dollar
amount of advertising revenue but in the
and you could ask yourself in advance
what would the what might be sort of
perverse incentive there be and it would
be to get someone to spend a lot of
money upfront which could lead to
advertiser disappointment because it's
front-loaded and then a high churn rate
and so how can you when you have a
metric for what you desire how could you
what metric could you look for or create
to track what you don't desire and it
could be say a high churn rate and so if
you're thinking of assumption number one
they're always going to be unintended
consequences to any material actions so
how can you how can you measure them how
can you track them I think it's so
important what we just mentioned well
Stuart it is such a joy and such an
honor to have a chance to spend more
time with you on the phone like this and
in conversation it's it's so much fun
for me and is there any particular place
that people can check out that you'd
like them to check out online or places
where they could say hello to you on
social media okay I'm on Twitter Stuart
brand and the long now foundation is as
a website gwanghae org
that has all sorts of things and we have
a bar in San Francisco
I think there's relatively few
nonprofits that have a bar
formation that people are welcome at and
all sorts of things are there that's the
interval yeah that's the interval and
that was the interval org and then
revived restore org is the place where
the genetic rescue projects I'm talking
about we're going on we started that
within long now as a project and now
it's gone independent is its own 501 C 3
charging ahead with saving various
species in various ecosystems
genetically well Stuart brand I thank
you so much I really appreciate all the
all the time I've learned a lot I've
taken many many notes as I hope other
people have so I just want to express my
gratitude for you taking the time well
you make it fun for your interviewees so
keep up the good work alright and
everybody listening as always and this
is going to be one hell of a set of show
notes you can find links to everything
that we've talked about in the show
notes at tim blog forward slash podcast
for this episode and every other episode
and until next time and as always thank
you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell them out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec founded by the genius Finn's
who lit the internet on fire and you may
have heard of their mushroom coffee
which features chaga and lion's mane
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm
I use it pretty much every day either
that or the chugga which is decaf is a
separate version and I use both these
primarily for focus and productivity
they just get you going let you up like
a Christmas tree so definitely check it
out people are always asking me what I
use for cognitive enhancement and for
right now this is the answer I try to
force this on all of my houseguests it
is a hell of a thing if I have employees
or people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect it's a lot more out of
them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this
the coffee tastes like coffee it takes
just seconds to prepare with hot water
and oddly enough only includes 40
milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you'd get in a regular
cup of coffee I don't get any jitters
acid reflux or any stomach burn any of
that it's very unusual and very very
cool so if you don't like caffeine they
also offer very strong but caffeine free
mushroom elixirs which I will sometimes
have in the evening I find chaga
specifically to be very very grounding
and earthy so that is another option and
I have a cupboard full of their products
at the moment which is right around the
corner of my kitchen you can try
something you can try a sample pack
which is great also right now by going
to four sig Matic calm for Tosh Tim
that's for sig Matic fo you are SI g ma
TI c comm /t Tim and use the code tim TI
m to get 20% off of your first quarter
and they're not that expensive anyway if
you were in the experimental mindset I
do not think you'll be disappointed so
try them up this episode is brought to
you by peloton and I'd heard about
peloton over and over again but I ended
up getting a peloton bike in the whole
system after I saw my buddy Kevin Rose
I've known him forever some of you know
and he showed up at my gate at my house
a while back and he looked fantastic hey
I asked was a dude you look great what
the hell have you been up to he's always
doing a weird diet or another but it
only lasts like week of two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin
but it really piqued my curiosity ended
up getting a system and it's become an
integral part of my week I love it and I
really didn't expect to love it at all
because I find cycling really boring
usually but peloton is an indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home
you know if worried about fitting
classes in your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute etc
new classes are at it every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and his eyen high-intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's fo n e PE l OT o n one peloton
calm and enter the code Tim all caps TI
m at checkout to receive $100 off
accessories with your peloton bike
purchase now you might say that
accessory is wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces know the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory category so there's
$100 off is a very legit hundred dollars
off so if you want to get in your
workouts
if you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high-intensity
interval training or anything else or
you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone
check out pillowtop one pallet uncom and
enter the code Tim again that's Oh N EPE
l o t-- o-- n dot-com and enter the code
Tim a check out to receive $100 off any
accessories including the shoes that you
will want to get check it out one pillow
chong kham code Tim
you